Hey everyone. My name is Nishant Gupta.
I'm a software engineering tech lead at
Meta, working on building the training
and inference infrastructure.
And today, we're going to be talking
about building deterministic
infrastructure for non-deterministic AI
agents.
So, most of the conversations around AI
over the last few years has been focused
on models. Bigger models, more
parameters, better reasoning.
But as organizations move from chatbots
to autonomous agents, a different
problem emerges. The challenge is no
longer in intelligence.
The challenge is is reliability.
At Meta and across the industry, we are
seeing agents move beyond answering
questions
and beginning to plan, call tool calls,
coordinate workflows, and make decisions
that affect production systems.
These systems are fundamentally
probabilistic.
Infrastructure is not allowed to be.
Today, I want to discuss this topic in
more detail.
The modern cloud infrastructure evolved
around a set of assumptions. A request
Most of the requests are short-lived.
Services are deterministic, more or
less.
Execution paths are known. Failures are
bounded.
However, autonomous AI agents violate
nearly every one of those assumptions.
They're stateful. They're long-running.
They make decisions dynamically. They
may may execute different workflows for
same inputs.
This is what I call the great mismatch.
We're trying to run autonomous systems
on infrastructure that was designed for
deterministic workflows.
This is probably the most important
mindshift. Most AI demos showcase
capability.
But can it solve a problem? Can it use a
tool? Can it compete complete a
workflow? Production systems be have a
different objective.
Can it do it reliably? Can it do it
10,000 times, 100,000 times, million
times?
Can it recover from failures? Can it
operate safely? Can it do it in an at an
acceptable cost with an acceptable
latency? With an acceptable outcome?
The majority of the engineering effort
moves below the model layer into
orchestration, monitoring, safety
evaluation, and recovery systems.
When people hear AI failures, they
immediately think hallucinations. In
reality In reality, hallucinations are
often the least interesting failure
mode.
What we see instead are infrastructure
failures, recursive reasoning loops,
workflow dead locks, retry
amplification, context corruption,
memory poisoning,
cost explosions. The model makes a
mistake, but however, the infrastructure
turns that mistake into an outage.
That's the real challenge.
So, as this slide shows a pattern that
distributed system engineers will
probably recognize immediately, an agent
calls a tool incorrectly, the tool
returns an error.
Instead of recovering, the agent
generates a slightly different, but
still invalid request.
The cycle repeats. Each retry consumes
more compute.
Reasoning depth increases, GPU
consumption rises, eventually you get
exponential resource growth.
What started as a minor API error became
a compute incident. This is why unco-
uncontrolled retries are one of the
biggest risk in agentic systems.
This is the architecture principle I
recommend most strongly. Never let the
model directly control production
systems.
The model should generate proposals,
infrastructure validates them, policy
engine approves them, execution gateway
enforces them. The model just suggests,
the platform decides.
This separation allows us to build
reliable systems even when the
underlying model remains probabilistic.
As we know, containers gave rise to
Kubernetes, microservices created
service meshes.
AI agents are creating something new, an
agentic control plane.
This layer becomes responsible for
scheduling, memory coordination, policy
enforcement, evaluation, monitoring,
workload routing, which is very
important.
And think of it as an operating system
for autonomous AI. The organizations
that build this layer will have
significantly more competitive
advantages.
So, traditional logs tell us what
happened. Agentic systems require
understanding why it happened. We need
traces to capture planning decisions,
tool calls,
memory lookups, state transitions. When
debugging an autonomous workflow,
understanding the chain of decisions and
reasoning is often more important than
the final output. Observability becomes
multi-dimensional.
Without it, production debugging becomes
nearly impossible.
So, as you can see, memory is one of the
most underestimated challenges in
agentic architectures. Once multiple
agents share state, familiar distributed
system issues appear. Stale reads,
conflicting updates, context drifts,
inconsistent views. The challenge
becomes even harder when memory itself
may be probabilistic and
retrieval-based. Many multi-agent
failures are actually consistency
failures masquerading as reasoning
failures.
So, safety cannot be a single component.
It must be layered. Prompt level
controls, tool permissions, policy
validations, human approvals, audit
systems.
Each of these layers catches a different
class of failures.
Defense in depth is a well-understood
security principle. It applies equally
well to autonomous AI systems.
Many people frame human involvement as
temporarily temporary necessity. I don't
think that's correct. The most
successful systems are likely to remain
human supervised.
Humans became become exception handlers.
They review ambiguous situations. They
handle normal scenarios. They provide
calibration signals.
The goal is not to remove humans. The
goal is allocating human attention where
it provides the maximum value.
So, one of the biggest infrastructure
shifts is that AI workloads increasingly
resemble cluster scheduling problems.
Demand is bursting. Reasoning depth is
and
Workflows may run for minutes instead of
milliseconds. Resource requirements vary
dramatically.
As a result, GPU efficiency, workload
placement, elastic capacity management,
and scheduling becomes critical.
Inference is no longer just a model
problem. It becomes a resource
orchestration problem.
The good news is that many of these
problems are not entirely new.
Distributed systems have solved
something similar for decades.
Circuit breakers become tool isolation.
Rate limits become agent limits. Retries
become control recovery. Resource quotas
become cost governance. Observability
becomes agent tracing.
Instead of inventing entirely new
infrastructure, we can adapt to
reliability patterns for autonomous
systems.
The industry has gone through several
phases. The initially prompts were the
differentiator. Then the models became
the differentiator. And both are rapid
rapidly commoditizing.
The next frontier is infrastructure. The
organization that won't that wins is not
necessarily have the best prompts.
They'll have the most reliable systems.
The competitive advantage is moving up
the stack.
If there's one thing I want you to
remember, it's this.
AI agents should be treated as
distributed systems. Models are
stochastic. Infrastructures must be
deterministic.
Reliability is increasingly an
infrastructure problem. Observability is
mandatory. Control planes are emerging
as a foundation layer. And ultimately,
the future of the AI AI won't be won by
better prompts. It will be won by better
systems.